j'ai enfin un contrôle de votre
établissement ce qui concerne les soldes
d'hiver donc je vais faire un tour de
votre magasin pour vérifier l'affichage
des prix et comment vous avez mis en
place l'opération solde les 15
contrôleur de la direction
départementale de la protection des
populations des Yvelines sont sur le
pont durant les six semaines des soldes
d'hiver ils vont effectuer environ 10
contrôles chacun et ils doivent ouvrir
l'oeil premier contrôle l'affichage des
prix ce sac est correctement étiqueté
pour les soldes donc on a une annonce en
pourcentage de réduction et en plus on a
le prix du sac donc le prix de référence
qui est barré avec le prix effectif qui
sera participé pendant les soldes donc
là c'est très bien on a une double
information auprès du consommateur
deuxième contrôle l'homogénéité des
réductions proposées le pourcentage
s'étend de -20 à -50% donc il est aussi
intéressant de vérifier que
qui est autant de -50% que de -30 et que
de -20 c'est pour informer le
consommateur qui va faire une bonne
affaire sur plusieurs
articles qu'il aura son choix troisième
contrôle la date de mise en rayon des
articles soldés tous les articles d'une
boutique peuvent être soldées à la seule
condition qu'ils étaient mis en vente
donc c'est à dire proposer à la vente au
moins un mois avant le début de la
période des soldes j'ai quand même
appris lors de ce contrôle qu'il fallait
effectivement indiquer la date de début
de sol ce que je ne savais pas donc je
le ferai dorénavant et oui la date de
début des soldes doit être clairement
indiquée en vitrine autre point
important la distinction entre les
articles soldés et ceux qui ne le sont
pas notamment par des étiquettes de
couleurs
au final cette boutique passe le
contrôle avec succès dans le cas inverse
la DDPP aurait fait des recommandations
et serait revenu contrôler la boutique
lors des prochaines soldes pour vérifier
leur mise en application les soldes
divers se termine le 12 février